you guys congratulations thank you oh
thank you
of course so i want to talk a little
about you know you guys have won this
four times before but especially you tj
tonight you mentioned in your speech
just kind of how emotional this will be
this win means
yeah
it felt like love wins tonight if you
don't mind just kind of talk a little
bit more about that
well i mean i think a lot of people
excuse me like even myself you know when
i came out i did not know what the
how that would be recepted and of course
i after that happened there was a lot of
positive people giving me support and
loving me and then the numbers apart
were like does that actually like what
does that mean you know like does that
turn into a good pat on the back and
like you know see you later
um and so to go out there tonight and to
actually see people really truly like
meaningfully
um invest in who we are and and support
what we're doing and what we're about i
thought okay this is this is not just a
friendly like i love you text this is
like people really uh wanting to pick us
up lift this up and carry us on um
and so that's where i really felt like
tonight it was
out of all the crazy [ __ ] in this world
that's going on right now and gets a lot
of attention um
that you know something very positive
happened tonight and it was just so
wonderful to experience that
congrats thank you thank you
congratulations my friends thank you sir
how are you thank you
hey i got the tour earlier this year
about a couple of weeks ago and it seems
like your fan base is just so strong
and into you guys and at the end of the
show you came out your little skeleton
outfit
talk a little bit about how this fan
base has played a role in you guys
becoming do over here and moving forward
with country music
you know to to
be honest none of us would be here
without fans and people mention that a
lot because it's true i mean
you know we can get on stage and pet
ourselves on the back that we want
awards and we're doing all these things
but if fans aren't showing up showing up
to the shows then frankly
it's really not working you know and we
show up especially kind of like during a
pandemic a soft pandemic if you will um
and people are out there kind of risking
potential illness to see us play and
it's kind of wild you know to see that
kind of love and feel that kind of love
and you know the awards are amazing all
of these things are amazing but nothing
touches the the the feeling that you get
when you get out out there in front of a
fan base that loves and appreciates what
you do
thank you